في الساعه ثانيه ونصف صباحا بتوقيت موسكو
بدا هجوم المسيرات التي تتهم روسيا
غريمتها اوكرانيا بالوقوف ورائه 16 دقيقه
تفصل المسيره الاولى التي انفجرت فوق قصر
مجلس الشيوخ وتسببت بحريق وبين الثانيه
التي تحطمت على اراضي قصر الكريم كما تقول
موسكو كيف نفت لتهام واعتبرته العوبه
الروسيه لحشد مزيد من الدعم للرئيس الروسي
في ظل غياب النصر العسكري تصريحات تماشت
مع موقف واشنطن التي اعتبرت ان الثقه
مفقوده في اي تصريح او اتهام يخرج من
الكرملين اما الامم المتحده فدعت موسكو
وقياد لوقف اي تصريحات تؤدي للتصعيد ونحن
معكم مستمرون في تغطيتنا لتطورات الاحداث
في موسكو فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اكرر هذه الرساله واعتقد انها ستكون على
الاقل مفهومه للجميع نحن لا نهاجم بوتين
او موسكو نحن نقاتل على اراضينا نحن ندافع
عن قرانا ومدننا ليست لدينا اسلحه كافيه
لهذا السبب لا نستخدمها في اي مكان لم
نهاجم بوتين لكننا نترك المجال للمحكمه
وفي نفس السياقه اكد مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ان لا علاقه اوكرانيا بالهجوم
الذي استهدف الكريملين بطائرات مسيره
موضحا ان مهاجمه الكريم ليست هدفا
لاوكرانيا
فيما يتعلق بالطائرات بدون طيار فوق
الكرملين فالامر واضح تماما اولا وقبل كل
شيء بالطبع اوكرانيا لا علاقه لها بها
لانها لا تحل اي مهام عسكريه ثانيا من
المهم بالتاكيد بالنسبه لنا تدمير جميع
الاهداف العسكريه الروسيه في اراضينا
لتسريع عمليه انهاء الاحتلال وهذه مهمه
استراتيجيه ذات قيمه ثالثا ستفسر روسيا اي
اعمال اخرى على انها اعمال ارهابيه ما
سيتيح لها تبرير هجماتها الارهابيه واسعه
النطاق ضد المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه
المدنيه في اوكرانيا لذلك من المهم للغايه
الابلاغ عن حدثين غريبين حدث اليوم الاول
كان احتجاز الوخربين الاوكرانيين
المفترضين في القرن والذين قيل انهم
يخططون الارتكاب عمل ارهابيه ثانيا تشير
الطائرات بدون طيار فوق الكرملين الى ان
روسيا تعد خلفيه معلوماتيه معينه لتبرير
اعماله ا الارهابيه واسعه النطاق لذا
دعونا نرى ما الذي ستفعله روسيا اؤكد مره
اخرى ان مهاجمه بطائرات بدون طيار ليس
هدفا لاوكرانيا
وفي تصعيد خطير قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي فان لا خيار امام روسيا
الان بعد الهجوم على الكرملين سوى قتل
الرئيس الاوكراني
واعضاء حكومته واضاف لا حاجه لبقاء الرئيس
الاوكراني على قيد الحياه ليوقع على
استسلام اوكرانيا فدائما هناك بديل على حد
وصفه
مجلس دوما الروسيه دعا لتوجيه رد خاص على
محاوله استهداف الكريم التي كانت تهدف
لاغتيال الرئيس بلد ميرفوتين حيث قام
باطلاق نداء لتدمير بعد الهجوم على
الكرملين وقال مجلس الدمى الروسي بان
الهجوم على الكرملين سبب لاطلاق حرب
حقيقيه باوكرانيا وبان الوقت حان لاطلاق
هجوم صاروخي على مقر اقامه الرئيس
الاوكراني
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتر بلينكن قال
ان واشنطن لا يمكنها التحقق من صحه تقارير
استهداف بوتين في الكرملين بمسيره واضاف
بلينكن ان امريكا تنظر بعيني الريبه لكل
ما يزور عن الكريم واكد انها لا تعرف ما
الذي حدث بالضبط كما قال بلينكن ان قرارات
اوكرانيا لكيفيه الدفاع عن نفسها تعود لها
و واشنطن واثقه بانها ستنجح باستعاده ما
تبقى من اراضيها
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو نشره الكرملين ما
يرجح انهما رجل ام كان يصعدني على قبه
المبنى قبل استهداف المسيره بثوان هذا
وقام الكريم بنشر فيديو لاستهداف الذي جرى
فجر اليوم حسب تقديرات اوليه ولم يذكر ما
اذا كان رجل الامن في مهمه امنيه لاعتراض
او التشويه على المسيرتين مؤكدا في بيان
عدم وقوعي اي ضحايا او اضرار ماديه
قال رئيس مجموعه
ان اوكرانيا بدات الان هجومها المضاد
واضاف في بيان له عبر تطبيق تيليجرام ان
قوته لاحظت نشاطا غير معهود للقوات
الاوكرانيه على طول الجبهه كما توقع ان
تنتقل للشباكات الى مرحله اكثر نشاطا في
الايام القليله القادمه
ونعود الى موسكو مره اخرى وتنضم الينا من
امام الكرملين
مرحبا بك كاتيا الاجواء في محيط الكريم
كانت تشير الى تعزيزات عسكريه امنيه ولكن
ايضا هناك تصريحات سياسيه قويه
كيف تبدو الاجواء لديك
مرحبا رشا بالفعل يعني هي تصريحات
الكرملين هي تاتي ضمن التصريحات التي
شهدناها منذ منذ
الصباح الذين دعوا الى طبعا الرد على هذا
الاستهداف الذي جرى يوم امس للكرملين بان
يكون هذه المره هذه تكون مرحله جديده قد
بداتها العمليه العسكريه الروسيه بان تكون
الرد قاسي وان يتم استهداف مركز القياده
الرئاسيه
لاوكرانيا في ان يتم استهدافها باسلحه
جديده كما تحدث رئيس مجلس سدومه وكما تحدث
ايضا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي الذي
دعا الى تحييد او القضاء على الرئيس بعد
هذه الخطوه التي تعتبرها موسكو هي بمثابه
اختراق كبير اولا
استهداف شخص الرئيس الروسي
بانه عمل ارهابي كما وصفه الكرم اليوم
يستهدف كان الرئيس الروسي
وبالتالي ان روسي كما قال مجددا انها
ستقوم بالرد على هذا استهداف بالوقت
وبالطريقه التي تختارها موسكو وطبعا اهميه
او هذا الحدث هو ياتي قبيله عيد النصر
الذي ستجده موسكو خلال الايام المقبله في
التاسع من هذا الشهر الجاري وتحضيرات هي
على قدم وساقتي
في الساحه الحمراء الامن مشدد بشكل كبير
يمنع دخول الماره ومرور السيارات بجانب
طبعا
[موسيقى]
هناك انتشار واسع للامن وبالاخص بعد
الحادث الذي وقع يوم امس
تقارير صحفيه تشير الى ان ما يدور في
اروقه الكريم الان وفي مجلس الدوما ايضا
هو ضروره القيام بعمل عسكري خلال الساعات
القليله القادمه ردا على استهداف الكريم
هل من معلومات في الاوساط السياسيه
والعسكريه حول هذا الامر
يعني هو
حتى القدر رشا كما اعتدنا على موسكو انها
لا تقوم بالحديث عن الخطوه التي ستقوم بها
بالرد على اي تصرف من جانب الاوكراني ولكن
روسيا دائما توعد وكنا قد شهدنا من
التجارب سابقه لها عندما تم استهداف جسر
القرن كان هناك رد مباشر بقصف مكثف
لشاهدته الاراضي الاوكرانيه للبنيه
التحتيه سواء كان ايضا
لمراكز الطاقه او مستودعات الاسلحه لذلك
روسيا لا
الخطوات التي ستقوم بها ولكن هي تكون بها
بشكل مباشر كما اعتدنا عليها لذلك هناك
توقعات بان تكون روسيا الان بالرد بشكل
عسكري بايقاف الاراضي الاوكرانيه بقصص
المستودعات التي حكم لك وبالاخص ان روسيا
تفتهم الناس
تفهم امريكا بانها تقوم بشكل مستمر بتزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه وهذا ما تعتبره بانه
بان حربها ليست مع اوكرانيا وانما حربها
مع الغرب ومع حلف الناتو طيب ما هي رده
فعل الشارع الروسي على كل هذه التطورات
بدءا من هذا الهجوم وايضا ما يبدو من
السدادات لتوسيع امد الحرب وتوسيع ايضا
نطاقها
هو هذه هذه الحادثه هي مهمه جدا لانها اول
بيوم قبيله ايام من عيد النصر وهي بالنسبه
للمواطن الروسي طبعا هو هذا العيد ايضا
مقدس لانها طبعا هو يمس اجداده وبالتالي
روسيا تعتذر يعني هذه الخطوه هي تهديد كما
قال هو تهديد ليس فقط لشخص الرئيس الروسي
وانما الشخص
لروسيا باكملها وبالتالي هناك اولا ترقب
من قبل الشارع الروسي وتخوف من الخطوات
اللاحقه التي ستاتي بعد هذه بعد هذا
الحادث من قبل الجانب الروسي هناك طبعا
حجز للشارع الروسي والوقوف الى جانب
الرئيس الروسي بعد هذا الحادث وبالاخص كما
ذكرت لك ان روسيا تحتفل بعيد النصر وهذا
العيد هو يعتبر ذو اهميه كبيره لكل مواطن
وروسي وهذا الحادث الان ياتي بهذا التوقيت
بحجز لحجز الشارع الروسي للوقوف والانتفاخ
حول الرئيس الروسي
في العمليه العسكريه الروسيه التي بداتها
او التي بداها الرئيس السيسي في اوكرانيا
مراسله العربيه من موسكو شكرا لك كاتيا
ونذهب الى كيف مباشره الى الصحفي محمد
البابا مرحبا بك سيد محمد هناك تصيد واضح
في لغه التصريحات الروسيه
يتحدث عن استهداف سننسكي شخصيا ما دلاله
هذا التطور
يعني تعودنا خلال الفتره الاخيره او خلال
الغاز الروسي للاراضي الاوكرانيه ان يخرج
المتر
الرئيس الروسي السابق ويعني امين عام مجلس
الدفاع الاعلى الروسي بتصريحات عاليه
اللهجه او عاليه النبره خاصه كان يتحدث
بالسابق انها ان روسيا قد تضطر لاستخدام
الاسلحه التكتيكيه والاسلحه النوويه في
حال تم استهداف سياده روسيا هذا الحديث
كان قبل استهداف جسر قرش والان يعني يوجه
البوصله الى نحو شخص الرئيس فلادينسكي
ويدعو او يتحدث عن انه يجب ان تتم تصفيه
وفريق عمل هو يعني الحكومه التي معه لذلك
الجانب الاوكراني يعني ردت الفعل الشارعه
الاوكراني جاءت بسخريه حول هذه التصريحات
التي يعني بحسب مسؤولين اوكرانيين بحسب
مسؤولين في وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
سيكون هناك موقف لاوكرانيا تجاه هذه او
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه هذه تصريحات خلال
الساعات القليله المقبله خاصه ان يعني هذه
التصريحات تاتي في وقت ان الرئيس
الاوكراني فلادي هو خارج الاراضي
الاوكرانيه في زياره خاصه في الى فنلندا
ويعني الرئيس الاوكراني ومعظم
الجهات الرسميه الاوكرانيه نفت علاقه
اوكرانيا
بالهجوم الذي حصل او بالمسيره
بدا العمل عليها ترقبا لاي هجوم روسي وشيك
يعني يمكن القول خلال الاسبوعين او ثلاثه
اسابيع الماضيه كان هناك حديث ان روسيا قد
تقوم بعمل ما خلال فتره يعني بين عيدين
عيد العمال في الاول من مايو في الاول من
ايار وبين يوم النصر في التاسع من مايك
لذلك هناك استعداد كبيره خاصه هناك
استنفار كبير
يعني الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه التي
اختبرت خلال اليومين الفائتين باطلاق
مسيرات واطلاق صواريخ على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه قبل ثلاثه ايام كان هناك
استهداف بصواريخ للعاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
11 صاروخا تم اسقاطها فقط فوق العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف الليله الماضيه كان هناك
18 مسيره فوق سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
وكنا نسمع في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
اصوات انفجارات عندما كانت الدفاعات
الجويه تشقق مسيرات في محيط وفوق سماء
العاصمه الاوكرانيه الان هناك ترقب هناك
حذر هناك عدد من المواطنين غادروا العاصمه
الاوكرانيه الى مناطق اخرى خوفا من اي
عمليه عسكريه او او هجوم يتداول والجميع
يتحدث يعني الشارع الاوكراني يتحدث انه
ربما الليله او الليله المقبله سيكون هناك
رده فعل روسيه عبر استهداف العاصمه
بصواريخ وربما صواريخ متطوره لتصعيد او
لرد بشكل كبير على هذه اضطرابات او على
هذه العمليه التي نفتها اوكرانيا المتحدث
باسم الرئاسه الاوكرانيه سرجي نيكوفورف
نفا تماما وقال انه لا علاقه لاوكرانيا
بما حصل او بالهجوم الذي حصل على الكرملين
ليله امس في الموصل
الينا في هذا الجزء من التغطيه السيد
مكسيم ياساده العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
الطيران الوطنيه بكييف سيد مكسيم نحن امام
تطور خطير البعض يراه انه قد يكون بدايه
لحرب اكثر شراسه بين الجانبين ماذا ترى
ان فرص التصعيد بين الطرفين سوف تكون
كبيره في عقاب هذه الحادثه التي وقعت في
موسكو اليوم
ولكن من الواضح
ان هذا الامر قد تم فقط من قبل الجانب
الروسي بهدف التصعيد وحتى اللحظه لا نرى
اي دليلا دامغا عن هذا الامر وكن وحتى ان
النائب الرئيس قد
قام باجراء تغريده يطالب فيها بقتل
الرئيسكي
فمن المستحيل
ان يتم كما يعتقد ان يتم عمليه اغتيال
لقتل بوتين فما من سبب يدفع لهذا التصرف
اخذينا في الاعتبار
انه عندما كان هناك اختراق
لامنين للكرم
فتمت مباشره
اتخاذ الخطوات حول زياده الهجمات على البن
التحتيه في اوكرانيا وعمليات هجوميه واسعه
بدات تشن قبل كل اسبوع وكل وكل شهر
الامر الذي كان يرمي الى
القضاء على قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا لذا
من المؤكد فان
الاوكرانيين يدركون حقيقه الامر
وفعل هذا الامر من اجل فقط مثل
الاوكرانيين الذين
لم يتوقفوا عن مشاهده اسقاط هذه الصواريخ
وقتل المدنيين كما كان عليه الحال في
الاسبوع الماضي عندما قامت احدى القذائف
بقتل مجموعه من الاطفال الابرياء فهذا
الامر
على الضحك والابتسام عندما نرى تعليقي
موسكو على هذه لكن الجنرالات في اوكرانيا
يرون ان
بان هذه العمليه مستحيل ان تتم ان تنفذ من
قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
روسي ام انهم مستحيل من ناحيه التخطيط
لهذا الامر
خلال الاسابيع القليله الماضيه
[موسيقى]
وكان هناك بعض الصواريخ التي
وصلت عبر الحدود الروسيه
نحن
بمقدورنا ان نستهدف العمق الروسي لكن هذا
ليس هدفنا
وكما قلت من خلال عمليه التحليل بانه يمكن
ان يتم انتاجي مسيره تحلق لتلك المسافه
ومن ثم تستهدف اماكن استراتيجيه في روسيا
التي تقوم باطلاق الصواريخ على البنى
التحتيه الاوكرانيه لكن لكن بكل تاكيد لن
نقوم باستهداف الكريم للوفقا لما يتم
تداوله لانه من المستحيل بوتين لم يكن
موجودا هناك ولا يمكن ايضا ان تتم عمليه
اغتيال متذكرين ان روسيا تمتلك صواريخ
باليسيه وقاموا باطلاق مجموعه منها على
كييف ومن ثم قامت
وسائل الدفاع الجوي بالتصدي لها لكن لم
تستطع التصدي الى صواريخ كروز البالسيه
يمكن اطلاقها منذ الجانب الروسي في اي يوم
وقد يقومون
باستهداف منزل الرئيس
الاوكراني هذا مجرد جدل
الامر الذي يجعل الروايه الروسيه خاليه من
اي اسباب مقنعه
ليست مصادفه ان نرى ان يتم بيع هذه
الروايه الان في مطلع شهر مايو وعندما
باتت الاجواء
[موسيقى]
باتت مشمسه وتوقف موسم الشتاء والاوضاع
الجويه سوف تكون مئاتيه لشن عمليه الهجوم
المضاده التي كنا نعد له العده وهناك
معلومات كثيره تتداوله وسائل الاعلام حول
هذا الامر ولعل احد الاسباب الرئيسيه
لاستغلال الغرب ولوقف هذا العمل الهجومي
المضادى المضاد هو ان
يتم من خلال هذه الروايه وهذا ليس الا جزء
من الروسيه وما عكف السياسيون الروس على
قوله
بان الذين يدفعون الان لاستهدافي اوكرانيا
بصواريخيه لكن اوكرانيا وحلفائنا الغربيين
هم يدفعون باتجاه دعم اوكرانيا من اجل شني
العمليه الهجوميه المضاده التي لطالما كنا
ننتظرها هذا الجدل وقد يكون كافيا لفهم من
يقف في وجه ماء كل هذه الاحداث
لنفكر بصوت عالي بوتين من وجهه نظر الجميع
لا يحتاج الى مثل هذه المبررات ليقوم
بتوسيع عملياته العسكريه لماذا يمكن ان
يقدم بوتين على هذا السيناريو او هذه
المسرحيه كما تقولون في هذا التوقيت هو
ليس بحاجه من وجهه نظر الكثيرين لهذا
الامر
هو بحاجه اليهم
فعلى سبيل المثال في السنه الماضيه
الكرملين
كان قد قام بعمليه خرفا امني واضحه
وبعد تلك الحادثه التي طالت
احدى الجسور المهمه في القرن تم شني
مجموعه من الصواريخ الكبيره التي استهدفت
البنى التحتيه وقال بوتين انذاك بانهم لا
يقتلون ولا يقومون باستهداف الاعيان
المدنيه رغم وجودي ومقتل الالاف من
المدنيين وهذا ليس الا مثال فاضح على ما
يقوم به انه يسعى لقتل
بني شعبه والاوكرانيين الذين يعيشون في
اوكرانيا قبل ان يشن هذا العمل الهجومي
الكامل
هذا ما ينادي به بانه لا يرغب بقتل
المدنيين
لكنه لم يتوانى عن شن عمليه هجوبيه
ارهابيه من اجل تهديد وترهيب المعنويات
الاوكرانيه في المقاومه لانه حتى اللحظه
قد فشل فشلا ذريعا في اهدافه العسكري
لعلكم ترون استطلاعات الراي العامه التي
باتت كلها تنميل الى اجراء مفاوضات سلميه
وسعاده كافه الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي قمنا
التي التي
تقوم اوكرانيا بالدفاع عن اكثر واستعاده
اكثر من
90% منها واذا ما كانت عملياتنا للهجوميه
المضاده ناجحه وسطعنا اعاده ما تبقى من
اراضينا شبه جزيره القرن فهذا سوف يكون
مقتله على الصعيد السياسي اي مقتل بوتين
وهذا سوف يؤدي الى هلاك نظامه السياسي
ولهذا السبب
اقول انه من قصر النظر ان
تداول هذه الروايه في الوقت الذي نقوم فيه
باعداد العده للعمليه الهجوميه المضاده
فلنرى ما تحمله لنا الايام المقبله
القليله فانا متاكد بان هناك اشياء كثيره
سوف تحدث فمثلا هناك ثلاثه
صواريخ مسيره ثلاثه مسيرات قد تم اطلاقها
على كيف في اليوم بين الماضيين وكنا قد
اعتدنا في السابق على اطلاق عدد كبير منها
على مر السنه كامله
هو بعد ان نفذ مخزونهم قاموا بتعزيز هذه
الصناعه وفي الاسبوع الماضي كانوا قد
عادوا الى اطلاق تلك المسيرات في كافه
انحاء اوكرانيا وهذا الامر يتزامل مع
اعداداتنا للعمليه الهجوميه المضاده وهذا
الهجوم الذي يحكي عنه قد تم تنفيذه من قبل
الروس من اجل اخافه الاوكرانيين وحلفائنا
الاوروبيين
لدفعنا للحقول عن العمليه الهجوميه
المضاده
في جامعه الطيران الوطنيه باكي
يف اذا لمحمد البابا من كياب
مقر الرئاسه الروسيه تعرض لمحاوله هجوم
بطائرات مسيره اوكرانيه وفق ما اعلنت
موسكو
الكرملين كلمه تعني القلعه التي تحمي مركز
المدينه واهم الادارات فيها كل المدن
التاريخيه الروسيه تحتوي على كرملين خاص
بها المبنى ذو القبه الذي تابعنا لقطات له
هو مجلس شيوخ الكرملين الذي يطل على
الساحه الحمراء وهو اداره تابعه لرئاسه
الروسيه ويبعد قرابه 500 متر عن القصر
الرئاسي تابعنا لقطات الانفجار وكما اعلنت
موسكو فقد تم تعطيله وتفجير الطائرتين
المسيرتين بواسطه الدفاعات الالكترونيه في
الكرملين دون حدوث اضرار ماديه او بشريه
روسيا لم تعلن اي تفاصيل الا ان التحليلات
تشير الى ان الهجوم نفذ بواسطه مسيرات
تجاريه اطلقت من مسافه غير بعيده من شارع
مخوفايا غرب الكرملين
وعندم علينا من باريس دكتور انطوان بسبوسه
الكاتب السياسيه مرحبا بك دكتور انطوان
نحن امام روايتين الاولى روسيه تتهمك
بتدبير هذا الهجوم لاستهداف بوتين
من اوكرانيا تقول لم نقم باستهداف بوتين
اي روايتين هي اقرب للواقع والى اين
ياخذنا هذا المنحنى من الصراع
مساء الخير
ايا يكون الفاعل فهي قصه كبيره لان ما
استهدف هو قدس الاقداس في القلعه الروسيه
في العاصمه موسكو فهناك احتمالات كثيره
ولكن ليس عندنا اي دليل قاطع حتى ننسب هذه
الامور هذا الهجوم لفئه معينه احتمال
الاول ان تكون اوكرانيا سواء عبر
مخابراتها او عبر الحدود ولكن المسافه
طويله من الحدود الى موسكو
الاحتمال الثاني قد يكون هناك ضباط في
الجيش الروسي غاضبين على الفشل في
اوكرانيا بعد 15 شهر من بدء الحرب
واستنزاف القوات
الاحتمال الثالث قد يكون يعني المخابرات
الروسيه التي تريد ان تعطي ورقه
للرئيس بوتين حتى يضرب بشكل عنيف وبشكل
جديد وباسلحه نوعيه لم يستخدمها حتى الان
مثلا عندما يقول ان يجب قتل
الرئيسكي وحكومته فهذا يعني يعطي مؤشر حول
هذا الاحتمال ان يكون هناك رغبه في تبرير
مسبق لما سيجري في كياف لاحقا وحتى الساعه
ليس هناك اي دليل قاطع يسمح لنا بان يعني
نوجه صوره كافيه كامله متكامله لنقول من
عمل هذه الضربه هل التطورات تكتب عنوانا
جديدا لهذه الحرب دكتور لمرحله اكثر شراسه
اكثر
استخداما للاسلحه اكثر خسائر المرحله
الجديده تبدو بملامح مختلفه
في الواقع هذا تصعيد نوعي
ويعني ضربه بسيكولوجيه رمزيه
لحكام موسكو للرئيس بوتين وحكومته يعني
هنا قدس الاقداس وهذه الصور التي جرى
توزيعها من اخذها هذه هذا الانفجار على
قبه احدى قباب الكرملين يعني سؤال
فيها اهانه هذه الصوره فمن وزعها من
التقطها من وزعها
وماذا سينتج من ردود فعل على هذا العمل
القوي الذي ضرب قلب السلطه في موسكو هناك
لابد ان يكون تصعيد خاصه ان موسكو على
موعد مع الاحتفال بالنصر بعد ايام معدوده
وربما الرئيس الروسي لا يستطيع ان يدعي
انتصارات في اوكرانيا فعليه ان الضربه
قاسيه وقاسمه
وقد يكون
يهيئ لمثل هذه الضغط في هذا الصراع دكتور
ان نصل لمرحله استهداف بوتين شخصيا او
الوصول الى عمق الروسي واهانه مؤسسه كبيره
كرملين وفي المقابل الرد الروسي ايضا بانه
سيتم استهداف ذلنسكي نفسه نحن نتحدث عن
مرحله من التصعيد تصل الى الهرم الراس كيف
يمكن قراءه ذلك
اعتقد ان المسيرات التي ضربت الكريم مساء
امس
ليست لا تستهدف قتل الرئيس لانه الكريم
يعني مدينه الى حد ما ومثل هذه المسيرات
لا تعطي اثر كبير فاذا كان هناك استهداف
للرئيس
بسياره مفخخه
بقتل عمد من قبل حراسه ولكن مسيرات من هذا
من هذا الحجم الضعيف لا يمكن ان تستهدف
اغتيال رئيس ولكن رمزيتها كبيره
وبسيكولوجيا صحيح انها تضرب
المعنويات الروسيه لدينا تطور ع وتابع
التطورات العاجله كما نشاهد مع حضراتكم من
اطلنطا هذه استعدادات امنيه في محيط
اطلنطا لوقوع حادث ما وقوع اصابات
نتيجه اطلاق نار لم تفصح السلطات حتى
اللحظه في اطلنطا عن تفاصيل حول هذا الامر
ولكن هذا حادث لاطلاق النار وفقا للمؤشرات
الاوليه ادى الى وقوع بعض الجرحى ولكن
ليست هناك تفاصيل هذا تكثيف امني كبير في
محيط الحادث ونحن سنقل عين عليها للمتابعه
اعود مره اخرى دكتور انطوان بسبوس اليك
لتحليل هذا المشهد من جديد نحن نتحدث في
مرحله سابقه عما كان يقال عنه انه يمكن ان
يصل الصراع الى مرحله اغتيالات سياسيه
ولكن البعض يرى الان ان ليست اغتيالات
سياسيه على المستوى العادي ولكن نتحدث عن
الرئيس الروسي عن الرئيس الاوكراني زينسكي
اذا هذا ربما فارق كبير في الصراع هل
امريكا على استعداد ان يصل التصعيد لهذا
الامر وكيف ستتصرف اذا كانت اوكرانيا قد
اقدمت بالفعل على هذا الامر
في الواقع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قالت لاوكرانيا بشكل واضح وصريح الاسلحه
التي نعطيكم اياها لا يجب ان تستخدمها فوق
الاراضي الروسيه انتم على حق اذا
استخدمتموها لاستعاده اراضيكم المعترف بها
دوليا ولكن ليس لضرب روسيا في العمق
الروسي وخاصه في العاصمه فلذلك انا اعتقد
ان الولايات المتحده لا تريد ان تؤجر
الصراع وحتى وانها اليوم تساند وما تزال
وتريد
المسانده الكامله
وحكومته ولكن لا ترغب ابدا في توسيع نطاق
الحرب سواء جغرافيا او حتى نوعيا طيب
دكتور نطرح بعض الاسئله اذا ما صحت اذا ما
صحت الروايه الروسيه ولا احد يعلم اذا كان
صحيحه او لا هل يمكن ان تكون اوكرانيا قد
اقدمت على هذا التغير الكبير كما ذكرت انت
النوعي الذي يمكن ان يقلب المعادلات بشكل
كبير دون الرجوع الى الحلفاء
من الممكن ان يكون الاوكرانيون قد نفذوا
هذه العمليه من دون مشاوره الحلفاء وما
شهدناه منذ 15 شهر هي قدره الاوكرانيين
على
اختراع وسائل ليست كلاسيكيه لضرب الروس
سواء في اوكرانيا او حتى خارج اوكرانيا ما
حصل قبل يومين من ضرب مثلا
للبنزين لمحطات البنزين او الاحرار
لمخزانات
البنزين في في القرن كان شكل يعني مهم جدا
وما حصل قبل في الصيف مثلا عندما ضربوا
الجسر الذي يصل روسيا بالقرب كان نوعيا
ممتازا يعني كان ضربه قويه جدا يا هل ترى
قبل اسبوع من العرض في الساحه الحمراء هل
استطاعوا ان
يت لايصال مثل هذه
المسيرات الى سقف الكريم فاذا كان ذلك لم
يعترفوا به
ولن يعترفوا بذلك وهناك عدد من الامور في
في هذه الحرب لا نعرف لمن ننسبها مثلا
الخط
الذي يوصل الغاز في
في البحر من فجره
هي هل ترى الروس الامريكان البريطانيين
الاوكرانيين هناك الغاز ما تزال في
مستوى الالغاز وربما في المستقبل نعرف
دكتور هذا التصعيد الخطير في الموقف الان
هل هو تصعيد يصل بنا الى نقطه لا عوده في
هذا الصراع ام انه تصعيد يمكن ان تعقبه
تهدئه
اعتقد ان هذا الصراع لن يحل عسكريا لانه
روسيا بلاد ثريه وقويه وان كانت اليوم
يعني بوضع بوضع دقيق وتستدعي
تشتري السلاح من ايران من الصين من كوريا
ولكن عندها الوقت عندها 140 مليون شخص
عندها نظام قبضه حديديه لا يمكن للناس ان
تتنفس يعني عندها نفس طويل في حين ان
اوكرانيا
اربعين 45 مليون شخص
وعندها سند غربي ولكن الغرب يعني مفكك الى
حد ما الا انه كان وما زال يساند الرئيس
زيلينسكي في الدفاع عن ارضه ولكن ماذا
يحصل اذا وصل ترامب او احد الجمهوريين الى
السلطه في البيت الابيض بعد سنه هذا سؤال
يسمح لنا بان نقول يجب ان
ينهو الميدان ينتهوا من ساحه الميدان من
الحرب
ويتوجهوا الى طاوله المفاوضات
لوقف هذا هذا الاجرام الدامي في اوكرانيا
دكتور هناك اعتقاد دائما بان الاقمار
الصناعيه وتطور التكنولوجي يستطيع ان يوضح
كل شيء هل يمكن بالفعل ان تفصح الاقمار
الصناعيه الدوليه خاصه وان هناك تلميحات
من امريكا في هذا الشان ان تحقيقا بشكل
بشان ما ترصده الاقمار الصناعيه يمكن ان
يقول حقيقه ما حدث
اعتقد ان الاقمار الصناعيه ترصد كل شيء كل
شيء حتى انه في بدايه الحرب الاقمار
الصناعيه
والتنصت على الهواتف جنريرات روسيا سمحت
للامريكان بان يعطوا مواقع هذا هؤلاء
الجنرالات وشاهدنا انه في خلال اسبوعين ما
يزيد على 20 جنرالا قتلوا في المعركه
من قبل الاوكرانيين
بمعنى اخر ان
التنصت والاقمار الصناعيه
القدره الامريكيه على يعني استطلاع كل ما
يرجع على الارض يسمح لهم بان يكونوا في
موقع متفوق في هذه الحرب وهذا ما اثبتوه
حتى الان حتى ان طائره التجسس الدرون
الامريكي الذي اسقط فوق البحر الاسود
شاهدنا انه
الفيلم الذي التقطه الدرون عندما ضربته
طائره روسيه كان موجود بمعنى اخر انه لا
شيء يختفي عن نظر الاقمار الصناعيه
والتجسس الامريكي الفنيه دكتور كنا نستمع
دائما لمعلومات عن الطيارات
المسيره او الدرون بان المشكله الكبيره من
الناحيه العسكريه انه لا يمكن ابطاء عملها
او عدم تحقيقها لاهدافها نحن امام بعض
التساؤلات الغريبه التي تتناقض مع
المقولات العامه كيف استطاع الطيران الجوي
او الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه التصدي لهذا
الهجوم نحن نفكر فقط فيما يقال
انا لست واثق من انه
شجره تصدي لهذين الدرون في في سماء موسكو
لانه لو لو كان ذلك صحيحا لا اسقطوهم خارج
اسوار القصر خارج الكرملين ولم يتركوا لهم
مجال الوصول الى قبه الكريم عفوا
انا اعتقد انه لو كان هذا الكلام صحيح
لكان اسقطوا المسيرات خارج اسوار الكرملين
وليس فوق فوق قبه الكرملين
لا انا لا اثق ان هناك جرى اسقاط
الدرونز
في ساحه هذا هو الفيديو الذي تم نشره هذا
هو الفيديو الذي تم نشره انه
الهواء هذا هو اصطدام اصطدام الطائره
المسيره بالقبه ولم اجد في هذا الفيلم لان
هناك
مضادات تصدت له ولو كان هذا صحيحا لكانوا
تصدوا له طيب هذا امر محير على كل الاحوال
دكتور الكل كان يراقب هذا الصراع الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وامال عريضه ان تنتهي
هذه الحرب هذا العام باعتبار ان تداعيات
الاقتصاديه سيئه للغايه على الجميع هل نحن
بعيدون عن هذا الحلم وفقا للتطورات
الحاليه
نحن امام موعد مهم جدا وهي الهجوم
الاوكراني لاستعاده قسم او بالاحرى كل
الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا هذا الهجوم
ينتظر الطقس وينتظر وصول المعدات الغربيه
وينتظر وصول السلاح والعتاد
في ضوء هذا الهجوم يمكننا ان نقوم مدى
فاعليه هذا الهجوم ومدى فاعليه الرد
الروسي على هذا الهجوم حتى الان 15 شهر
بعد بدء الحرب وهي كانت بنظر الكرملين
نزهه لوضع اليد على على اوكرانيا
والقبض على على السلطه في كييف نجد ان
هناك استنزاف للقوى الروسيه واهانه لقوه
روسيا التي كنا نتصور انها ثاني اكبر جيش
في العالم واذا بها بعد 15 شهر من بدء
الحرب نجدها ضعيفه ومنهاره الى حد بعيد
منذ قليل هل هو مجرد تهديد سياسي ام انه
امر قابل للتضييق فعلا وهو يتحدث عن
اغتياز المسكين
اعتقد ان
وهو رئيس سابق لروسيا عنده دور في
التهديد وفي تجاوز كل
الدبلوماسيه هو الذي يتحدث دائما وتكرارا
عن استخدام السلاح النووي وحتى الان رغم
الهزائم الروسيه لم يستخدم سلاح نووي هو
الذي يهدد وكانه موضوع في في هذه الحلقه
حتى يرفع الصوت حتى يرفع المعنويات حتى
يعني يخوف الغرب ويخوف الاوكرانيين ولكن
كل ما قال حتى اليوم لم يصدق اي قول اي
تصريح اي تهديد
فاعتقد ان مصداقيه على المحك وهو يعني في
كل هذه التصريحات نجد انه ضعيف وانه لا
يعبر عن جوهر ما ينويه الرئيس بوتين
لا هو مؤشر على ان هذا مجرد تصعيد في
اللغه وانه لن يؤدي الى تصعيد يستهدف
الرئيسين بالفعل ما هي الخطوه القادمه
التي يمكن ان نتوقعها ما هو التالي
اعتقد ان الموعد المقبل سيكون من ناحيه
كيفيه الرد الروسي على وصول المسيرات الى
الكرملين ومن ناحيه ثانيه علينا ان ننتظر
ما هو ما جدوى
الهجوم المرتقب من الاوكرانيين ضد الجيش
الروسي وفجنير في المناطق المحتله في ضوء
هذين الحدثين الاول اعتقد انه يكون سريع
وقبل احتفالات عيد النصر الاسبوع المقبل
والثاني اعتقد ان الاوكرانيين يستعدون له
بجديه وقد وصلهم العتاد وهم يعني اثبتوا
حتى الان جدارا قويه في الدفاع وفي الهجوم
وفي ضوء ما سينتج عنه هذا الهجوم المرتقب
يمكن ان نعيد ونقيم
الحرب
ومالاتها وعمه ستسفر عنه وكيف نجد او
نتصور نهايه لها اشكرك دكتور انطوان
بسبوسه الكاتب السياسيه من باريس تحياتي
[موسيقى]
من مقر الرسميه للرئيس ونوابه ومضايفه
للرؤوس الاجانب او للرؤساء الاجانب تحول
القصر الجمهوري الجديد بالسودان الى بؤره
رئيسيه للصرع القصر الجمهوري بات اكثر
النقاط اشتعالا الى جانب محيط القياده
العامه للجيش ومطار الخرطوم القصر مقره
العاصمه الخرطوم يتكون من ثلاثه طوابق من
يسيطر فعليا عليه حتى اللحظه واين تدور
للشبكات هذه هي اسئله الساعه هناك يتجاذب
طرف الصراع السيطره على الاقل اعلاميا
قوات الدعم السريع اعلنت سيطرتها على
القصر قبل اسبوعين لكن الجيش خرج مرارا
لينفي ما وصفه بالمعلومات المضلله
والكاذبه غير ان قوات الدعم السريع نشرت
قريبا فيديو لعناصرها من داخل القصر مؤكده
بسطه سيطرتها عليه واحتفاظها بمواقع
استراتيجيه اخرى بينها مطر الخرطوم
مقر الرئاسه الروسيه تعرض لمحاوله هجوم
بطائرات مسيره اوكرانيه وفق ما اعلنت
موسكو
الكرملين كلمه تعني القلعه التي تحمي مركز
المدينه واهم الادارات فيها كل المدن
التاريخيه الروسيه تحتوي على كريملين خاص
بها المبنى ذو القبه الذي تابعنا لقطات له
هو مجلس شيوخ الكرملين الذي يطل على
الساحه الحمراء وهو اداره تابعه لرئاسه
الروسيه ويبعد قرابه 500 متر عن القصر
الرئاسي تابعنا لقطات الانفجار وكما اعلنت
موسكو فقد تم تعطيله وتفجير الطائرتين
المسيرتين بواسطه الدفاعات الالكترونيه في
الكرملين دون حدوث اضرار ماديه او بشريه
روسيا لم تعلن اي تفاصيل الا ان التحليلات
تشير الى ان الهجوم نفذ بواسطه مسيرات
تجاريه اطلقت من مسافه غير بعيده من شارع
مخوفايا غرب الكرملين
ونحن نحاول ان نتابع مع حضراتكم الاحداث
في موسكو بكل تطوراتها وفي السودان بكل
تطوراتها سنعود مره اخرى الى موسكو
لمتابعه الموقف عسكريا وينضم الينا عبر
سكايب بافيل
المحلل العسكري مرحبا بك معنا على شاشه
العربيه سيد بابل هل بالفعل يمكن ان نقول
ان اوكرانيا قادره على الوصول الى العمق
الروسي ان تدفع بمصيرات الى الكرملين هذا
يمكن ان يحدث من الناحيه العسكريه
نعم لقد اظهر الاوكرانيون بانهم يمكنهم ان
يستهدفوا العمق الروسي
ويقال بينما يقال الان بان هناك عمليه
هجوميه التي شنت على وانهم لا يتحملون اي
مسؤوليه عنها لكن لديهم كما نعلم جمله من
العمليات هجوميه السابقه التي قاموا بشنها
من خلاله مسيرات طويله المدى وقصيره المدى
التي يتم
اطلاقها من مناطق محاذيه لروسيا واقاموا
بشنها هجمات على بعض مناطق المواصلات
والبنى التحتيه في جهد داخل روسيا نعم ان
القتال
مازال ينتشر ويصبح اكثر قربا من التربه
والاراضي الروسيه وهذا عامل مهم وهناك
حاله من الذعر
نوعا ما من في الاوساط الروسيه حول حول
مساله
التصدي لهذه الهجمات والمسيرات
وايضا انظمه الملاحه في الفتره الحاليه قد
لا تكون دقيقه بالشكل الكامل لان هناك
مخاوف
بان يكون عمليات هجوميه اخرى قد تحدث ولا
سيما عندما يقوم بوتين في التاسع من
سوف يقف في الساعه الحمراء في التاسعه
صباحا من اجل حضور مراسم
حفلي الانتصار العسكري سوف يكون
عرضه لبعض العمليات الهجوميه
التي قد تشتغل اوكرانيا الامر واطلاقها
مره اخرى طيب اذا نصحت الروايه الروسيه
بان المسيرات الاوكرانيه وصلت الى
الكرملين بالفعل الا يعد هذا بمثابه هزيمه
عسكريه او اشاره لضعف الاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه الروسيه
التي جعلت الاوكران يصلون الى الكرملين
نفسه
وموسكو لا تعلم شيئا
ينفون تورطهم بهذه الحادثه لكن
هناك حاله من الضعف في الدفاع في وجه تلك
المسيرات التي يتم اطلاقها لكن هذا الهجوم
على وجه التحديد حدث في الليل ولم يكن
بوتين موجودا بل كانت
موجودا في مقر سكنه الرئيسي في احدى
مقاطعه موسكو
وتحركاته كما تعلمون تتم بصوره سريه
ومساله
التاكد من اطلاق هذه المسيره سوف تكون
صعب يتوقعها وفي الاسبوع المقبل قد يكون
الرئيس في وضع محفوف في المخاطر في ظني
وجوده في التاسعه صباحا في الساحه الحمراء
لحضور احتفالات عيد النصر وهذا قد يكون هو
المكان معروف وتوقيت معروف الامر الذي
يحمل معه بعض المخاوف مخاوف الضعف الامر
الذي تاخذه موسكو على محمل الجزر طيب نحن
نحاول ان نطرح عليك بعض الاسئله التي تدور
في الاذهان الان اذا كانت بالفعل المسيرات
الاوكرانيه قادره على الوصول الى
الكرملين لماذا تحديدا تم التصدي لها في
هذه النقطه تحديدا تركت الى ان وصلت الى
قلب الكريم اذا كان من الممكن اسقاطها من
قبل لماذا تركوها تصل وهل سلاح المسير ات
كما نعلم في العلوم العسكريه العسكريه
يقال ان مشكله هذا السلاح انه لا يمكن
للدفاعات الجويه رصده بسهوله
لماذا لم يقوموا باسقاطها في البدايه
لاننا نتحدث عن مسيرتين لم يكن يتوقعا
انهما سوف يحدثان ضررا كبيرا في الامر
اشبهه بحرب نفسيه فمسيره صغيره
يرى البعض بانها لن تكون فعاله ضد اهداف
خرسانيه قويه ثابته
وكما تعلمون التاسع من مايو سوف يكون يوما
خاصا وقد يصبح وضع الرئيس بوتين المحفوفا
في المخاطر وهذا يذكرنا بما حدث في الحرب
اليمنيه عندما قامت بعض المسيرات باستهداف
في بعض المراسم العسكريه
وحملت معها نتائج كبيره مؤثره هذه مساله
حساسه بالنسبه للكرملين
ودرجه التصعيد في اعلى مستوياتها بسبب
الاحتفالات المرتقبه وضعف القياده الروسيه
اعيد سؤالي مره اخرى لان هذا الامر يبدو
فيه بعض الحلقات المفقوده الناس تسال
لماذا انتظرت موسكو الى ان وصلت المسيرات
الى الكرملين حتى وان كانت مسيرات ضعيفه
لن تحدث ضررا وكيف استطاعت ان تقوم بتفجير
هذه المسيرات دون اي اضرار
في روسيا كانت هناك انظمه دفاع جويه يتم
وضعها في اماكن مختلفه في موسكو في ذلك
منظومه
ولديهم ايضا بعض الصواريخ
وقد تم استخدامها من اجل تدمير اي مسيره
قادمه قد يكون هذا هو الاحتمال الاكبر
وكذلك انظمه الدفاع الجوي التي تم توصيبها
وتركيبها في اماكن محدده من اجل الدفاع عن
مناطق المحدده في موسكو بما في ذلك
قوه الدفاع هناك اعدادات قد تم اتخاذها
على قدم وساق لكن ما من اصابات بشريه وقعت
جراء الهجوم نعم سيد بابل فيلجين هاور
المحلل العسكري عبر سكايب من موسكو تحياتي
ونبقى في الاخبار الروسيه الاوكرانيه حيث
اعلنت جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي احباط
انشطه شبكه تابعه للمخابرات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه كانت تخطط لتنفيذ هجمات
ارهابيه في شبه جزيره القرم كما اكد
الجهاز في بيان ان المتفجرات التي تمت
مصادرتها من المعتقلين اثناء التحضير
لهجمات ارهابيه في القرن تتطبق مع تلك
المستخدمه في تسجيل خطوط السكك الحديديه
في 23 من فبراير الماضي
ستبقى روسيه للابد تعهد قطعه عام 2014 عند
ضم شبه جزيره القرمه وانتزاعها من الخريطه
الاوكرانيه غير ان انفجارات وغارات جويه
عده اظهرت وفق اعلام غربيه هشاشه الوجود
الروسي هناك كما ابرزت شبه الجزيره كجزء
من اهداف اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب للتغلب
على الرعب من الضروري ان ننتصر في المعركه
ضد العدوان الروسي وان نحرر القرم
الضربات الاوكرانيه في عمق شبه جزيره
القرم ومن ضمنها استهداف مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي في سيفا ستوبول هدفها
استنزاف اللوجستيات ومراكز القياده
والسيطره اي تعطيل خطوط الامداد الروسيه
اولا كما تهدف لعرقله توغل موسكو جنوبي
اوكرانيا ومخططها البرمائي للاندفاع غربا
باتجاه اوداسا وانشاء جسر بري الى مولدوفا
الا ان الضربه الكبرى تمثلت بالانفجار
الذي هز جسر كيرتش الحيوي في اكتوبر 2022
ما ادى لتدمير جزء منه وتعطيل حركه النقل
وان لفتره هذا الجسر هو الاطول في اوروبا
ويمتد لتسعه عشر كيلومترا بلغت تكلفه
تشييده ثلاثه مليارات وسته مئه مليون
دولار ويعد حلقه وصل بين شبه جزيره القرم
ومنطقه كريسنو دارك راي الروسيه شمالي
القوقاز نائب رئيس مجلس الدوما الروسي
وصفاح حينها الانفجار بمثابه اعلان حرب في
معدته الخارجيه الروسيه دليلا على ما
وصفته الطبيعه الارهابيه للحكومه
الاوكرانيه اما مستشار زيلنسكي فاكد ان
الانفجار مجرد بدايه طالما ان كل شيء غير
شرعي يجب تدميره وفق تعبيره
الضربات الاوكرانيه في شبه الجزيره جاءت
متقطعه على مدى اشهر الا ان وثيرتها
ازدادت بشكل كبير خلال الايام الاخيره وهي
وفق الوصف الروسيه تعتبر اعمالا ارهابيه
وتخريبيه يسعى لتفكيك شبكه منفذها
وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه التي تشهدها
الحرب الدائره على الاراضي اكد مراسل
العربيه بان قوات بجنر الروسيه تقدمت على
عمق المحور الغربي من مدينه بخموت وسيطرت
على مساحات اضافيه واشار الى ان المعارك
اشتدت حول الطريق السريع في بلده خرى شمال
غرب المدينه وكريسنايا في نفس المحور كما
وسع الجيش الروسي من تطويقه لمدينه افدى
بعد عمليه عسكريه عنيفه واشار الى ان قوات
الاوكرانيه شنت هجوما مضادا على الجيش
الروسي في مناطق القتال غرب مدينه
ماريناكا
في المقابل اعلنت السلطات المحليه
الاوكرانيه فرض حضر تجول في خرسون الواقعه
قرب خط المواجهه اعتبارا من مساء الجمعه
ولمده 58 ساعه واوضح رئيس الاداره
العسكريه المحليه على تيليجرام انه خلال
حظر التجول سيمنع التنقل في شوارع المدينه
اعلنت تليسينكي ان رئيس الاوكراني
وصل اليوم الى فنلندا في زياره مفاجئه
يشارك خلالها في قمه تجمع قاده دول الشمال
الخمس وقالت الرئاسه في فنلندا في بيان ان
زيلنسكي سيحضر القمه وسيقض مباحثات مع
الرئيس الفنلندي كما سيجرزكي محادثات
ثنائيه مع كل من رئيس الوزراء السويدي
والنرويجي والدنماركي وايضا رئيس وزراء
ايسلندا وفقا للمصدر نفسه
صراحه وفوضى الاوروبيه عن خطط ثلاثيه
الابعاد لتمويل اوكرانيا بالذخيره التي
تحتاجها للدفاع عن نفسها ضد روسيا بقيمه
مليار يورو حيث سيتم تمويل خطه انتاج
الذخيره وتوسيعها على الصعيد الاوروبي
خلال 12 شهرا اضافه الى تنظيم مشتريات
الذخيره بشكل جماعي بين شركه السلاح كما
ان المشروع سيطيح لاوكرانيا قرابه مليون
ذخيره لوقف النشاط العسكري الروسي
اكد المتحدث باسم الكرملين ان روسيا مهتمه
بتنفيذ جميع الاتفاقيات في اطار صفقه
الحبوب مؤكدا ان روسيا تواصل الاتصالات في
هذا الصدد وسط توقعات بان تحقق شروطها كما
ذكر بسكوبا ان الكريملين لا يرى سببا
حاضرا يدعو لتفاؤل بشان اتمام صفقه تمديد
مبادره تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
ونحن وصلنا لختام هذه الساعه ميسون معكم
على راس الساعه الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات